thank you so much I find your argument a
very compelling and I was just wondering
how do you see yourself or your actions
contributing to the global LGBT movement
worldwide because you know there's a lot
of other communities struggling out
there and I was wondering if you think
your own resources your experiences the
legislative strategy how do you see that
help other people attain their goals the
well you know the the hope is that it
absolutely will have a huge impact
worldwide there were a lot of incredibly
beautiful and powerful stories about
milk and the impact that that did have
worldwide it's actually a great
follow-up to the preaching to the choir
question because you know it's you know
in America in in West Hollywood or the
village or it you know big cities you
know gays who have feel like they are
have full rights even though actually
they don't but you know feel comfortable
and have successful lives and you know
they go to see milk and they're inspired
and they go back to their condo and have
white wine and go to sleep you know when
it showed in places in Europe and in
Asia and in Latin America where you know
it made a profound difference in
people's lives to even know that there
was someone like this and to see that he
had struggled and to be able to gather
and actually you know see a movie that
had gay content was like a you know a
transformative experience